We need someone to inspire us again
someone who can be a symbol for all of us
join me in welcoming your new captain america
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
falcon and winter soldier episode one video
marvel's next big disney plus series be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes i'll be
doing videos for all of the episodes just like
i did for Wandavision we're doing a disney plus
giveaway for memberships all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite moment from the episode on the video
our favorite easter egg careful for spoilers if
you have not seen the episode yet and careful for
spoilers from Wandavision episodes i'll explain
where this fits in the timeline in some of the
crossover easter eggs because obviously it's
marvel everything is connected but the episode is
titled new world order which is a reference to a
bunch of different story lines and subplots is a
reference to the aftermath of avengers end game
because it sort of deals with the direct aftermath
and what's going on in the world the chaos that's
happening that they've referenced the new version
of the super soldier program the weapons plus
program that we saw during incredible holds that
thunderbolt ross had jumped started because we see
the brand new version of captain america the us
agent john walker captain america it's a reference
to baron zemo's subplot during the series the new
flag smashers group which is sort of a separate
storyline although it's implied that all those
storylines are going to dovetail by the end of
the series in new world order as in the beginning
of falcon wielding the shield the new version
of captain america because that's kind of what
the series is about it's all about the process
of falcon eventually becoming the next captain
america but as you can see he starts in a really
low place but the episode begins about six months
or so after avengers end game so Wandavision takes
place between three and four weeks after avengers
end game like the Wandavision finale takes place
about four weeks after avengers end game so falcon
and winter soldier is taking place a couple months
after that they said the reason why they chose to
have the series take place during this particular
time period is because they wanted to get past the
honeymoon phase of the blip where everyone's just
excited to be alive again like yeah everyone's
back all my loved ones are back and now as you
kind of see during the episode reality has set in
and it's chaos everywhere everyone's kind of gone
back to being an to each other even falcon can't
even get a bank loan because they claim he hasn't
had income for the last five years even though
he had been snapped for that entire period but
the episode actually begins with him looking at
captain america's shield with the voice over from
old man captain america at the end of avengers end
game asking him how does it feel talking about the
shield he said it feels like someone else's and
then steve rogers captain america says it's not
as in it belongs to you like he really wanted
falcon to take the mantle of captain america
the dialogue is literally copy and pasted from
avengers end game and there obviously is the
question of what happened to old man cap after
this scene because everybody has these theories
they reference later in the episode there's a
theory that he's on the moon base don't worry
there's a bunch of easter eggs there i'll explain
what's going on with that in a second but then
they continue to open pretty much the exact
same way that they opened the captain america
winter soldier movie where you have like a brief
intro scene but then you really open with a giant
action scene in the winter soldier movie it was
the boat scene with hydra and batroc the leaper
so you can see how they're very literally copying
a lot of the beats from the winter soldier movie
because they brought back batroc the leaper
for a very similar type of opening action scene
the twist is here that it's the canyon fight
scene with falcon's newer wingsuit that we've
seen in all the trailers just meant to give you
a tutorial in the falcon character show you how
his systems how his tech works in a way that
they have in the previous avengers movies like
infinity war and game captain america civil war
even the winter soldier movie you see his heads
up display you actually learned that a lot of his
gear is stark tech and you see how his new version
of red wing the special drone that he's had in all
the previous movies works so he's had a version of
this in all the movies before it just each time he
shows up at a new movie it gets upgraded but the
group that he's after is called laf and they've
just targeted this captain that he's trying to
save vessant isn't a big comic book easter egg so
i think he's just a character they created for the
episode you learned that since avengers end game
falcon has been taking contracts with the air
force to earn money so he's not official military
like he used to be but it's a very mission
impossible tom clancy covert ops scenario like
don't get caught because the us is not supposed
to be operating in this area the lieutenant
torres who's helping him out on the ground his
sort of sidekick the intelligence officer is
a reference to joaquin torres from the comics
who is the second version of falcon who took the
mantle from sam wilson after he took the mantle of
captain america that doesn't necessarily mean that
this lieutenant taurus is going to become the next
falcon in the mcu because i don't know exactly
how they're going to make the transition to
falcon becoming the next captain america we'll
just have to see how that plays out in the series
the way he eats out of the plane is a reference to
captain america at the beginning of winter soldier
just eating out of the back of the plane without
a parachute did he just jump without a shoot yes
yes he did the scene of him surprising the pilot
peeping in the window is also very reminiscent of
the first iron man movie where iron man hugged the
bottom of the jet and just went for a ride with
the other pilots peeping him like wait a minute
there's a man attached to the bottom of the plane
they show you how the new version of red wing
works it's basically like a stark tech enhanced ai
drone like it has its own minor version of jarvis
or friday on it that he talks to like it's one of
his partners like he would talk to a human partner
like winter soldier the whole close quarters fight
that he has on the plane here also meant to be
very reminiscent of the close quarters fight that
captain america had on the boat at the beginning
of winter soldier couple twists though obviously
he's wearing the wingsuit so you see him use the
wingsuit in ways that he hasn't used it before
this time batroc the leaper escaping seemingly
unscathed as they continue the chase in the wing
suits just to show you more of what it looks like
when he's flying around in the canyons with it
the other reason for them opening with this
giant action scene here is to make it feel like
this is a movie just playing out in six hours six
different episodes the reason why they originally
wanted to drop falcon and winter soldier episodes
before Wandavision were just as a proof of concept
like look we can do these big avengers movies
on tv and it'll feel just like a movie you just
be watching it in six different parts so i'll
say after episode 1 mission accomplished this
definitely felt like a slam dunk big marvel
movie just done on tv but the fight kind of
escalates as they go along like his systems start
malfunctioning there's another helicopter that
joins the fight and starts firing on him they show
you how nimble he is with the wings in the air the
couple cool aerial takedowns then he just stealth
shows up on the helicopter when they're talking
about getting away like we're about to get away
scot-free he snatches that captain by threading
the needle right through batroc's helicopter
and even though he does complete his mission
successfully batroc the leaper does get away so i
believe that later in the series batroc will come
back there'll be a lot of other special cameos
that they'll have in the series like obviously
war machine was a big cameo rhodey was a big cameo
during this first episode he'll also probably come
back in future episodes the rest of this opening
scene with falcon and tunisia though they just
used to sort of reacquaint you with a character
let you know some of his other skills that maybe
you didn't see in the other avengers and other
marvel movies and give you an idea for what the
world is like post blip like you learn that he's
actually got engineering skills he's repairing
red wing himself like he makes a joke about how
the air force keeps messing it up when they try
to work on it the local businessman comes up to
thank him just because he's a cool dude like it
sounds like it wasn't part of his normal air force
work like he just helped the dude out because
he wanted to be nice then they introduced the
idea of the flag smashers group from the comics
the symbol of the red hand over the world so the
whole idea is that in the comics flag smasher is a
single character like he's a marvel villain in the
captain america comics but their whole operating
ethos is pretty much the same ethos of the marvel
comic book villain that they're based on they go
around trying to destroy world governments as this
really twisted way of bringing people together
but in the context of the falcon and winter
soldier episodes they explained that the flag
smashers group thought that the world was better
before the blip during that five-year time jump
because humans as a group were much more united
they were united because they were just trying to
survive now that everyone's come back after the
blip things have kind of gone back to default
where everyone's an to each other again but it's
not totally clear exactly what the flag smashers
plan is they sort of teased their group a little
bit later in the episode i'll talk about that too
falcon starts to get some ideas about what's
going on with them then they reference all the
conspiracy theories that people have about what
really happened to steve rogers captain america
after avengers end game like people knew that he
fought and helped defeat thanos but that's all
they know they don't know what happened to him
after the theory that he references about him
being on a secret base on the moon is actually a
reference to a couple storylines in marvel comics
the avengers have visited the moon many times
that's also where marvel's watcher in the comics
shows up a lot and there was a nick fury secret
base on the moon in the comics for a long time i
also believe it's meant to be a reference to nick
fury's space station from the spider-man far from
home post-credit scenes that he has with the
scrolls but the way falcon talks about it like
he tries to brush it off like no you don't have to
listen to any of those crazy conspiracy theories
as if he knows what's happened to captain america
but doesn't want to say they treat it like people
think that he's dead but i think there's going
to be a big twist with that so early theory it
is possible that he is living on nick fury's space
station in retirement but the whole idea is that
chris evans said that he wasn't planning on coming
back to the mcu right away but there have been
some rumors about that so we'll just see what kind
of easter eggs we see for his character during the
series they do reference him several times in the
episode then he says he's going back to washington
dc for quote unquote moon stuff that means captain
america stuff because he's taking captain america
shield to give it back to the government because
it does technically belong to the government
he gives this big speech about the meaning of
captain america the meaning of the shield the
symbolism the man behind the symbol being just as
important as the symbol itself this is all at the
smithsonian at the captain america exhibit
and they basically put it in the case there
war machine rhodey character is there because
he's also military just like falcon and it's
basically a military ceremony we also meet the
government official who unveils the john walker
u.s agent version of captain america at the end
of the episode i don't know who his character
is yet i didn't see him credited at the end of the
episode but he just seems like one of the military
officials who's behind this new version of the
weapons plus program he thanks falcon oh it was
the right thing giving us the shield back bringing
it back because it sounds like nobody knew what
happened to the shield after captain america went
to return the infinity stones they just thought it
was lost to time forever until falcon brought it
back like no i have it here here you go all the
chaos that he talks about during his speech too
that's sort of a callback to Wandavision with
monica rambo's storyline showing what the blip was
like in the moment like her body literally being
reassembled at the atomic level and when he talks
about the need for new heroes suited for the now
very different world that they're living in
post-alien invasion and massive god-level events
the phrase quote-unquote suited for today is
foreshadowing for falcon's eventual costume change
when he fully takes the mantle of captain america
like he's already got a brand new costume for the
falcon winter soldier series now the new falcon
costume but i believe he'll also get another new
captain america version of the falcon costume
so he will literally be suited for the new
challenges then you see that rhodey looks like he
actually got kids pissed off at him for giving the
shield back like dude what's the deal you were
supposed to keep that and take the mantle of
captain america he actually kind of takes them
to task through it as they're walking through
the captain america exhibit falcon says all of his
relatives are five years older because they didn't
get snapped which they pay off later when you meet
the rest of his family like he's got a sister with
a couple kids who are way older now because
they were not snapped rhodey also jokes about
teaching them how to fly the right way because
remember they're both pilots it's just they both
use different types of gear like he flies in the
iron man designed war machine armor but falcon
uses the wing suit then flat out asks him why
didn't you take the mantle of captain america
when he gave you the shield like he wanted you to
like that was what captain america was telling him
to do here take the shield that belongs to you
now the way anthony mackie explained this the
reason why falcon didn't just immediately become
captain america is because he said that he wasn't
totally happy with what was going on in america at
the time the falcon character wasn't super happy
like they tried to explain during the episode
the state of the world has kind of gone to crap
everything's chaos again and he didn't
want to become thunderbolt ross's patsy
and just do whatever the government told him to do
like remember steve rogers had a very contentious
relationship with the government after captain
america civil war after he became a fugitive he
actually darkened the star on his uniform because
captain america himself did not believe in what
the government was doing and didn't want to
be a symbol for that particular government
that's sort of where the u.s agent version of
captain america comes in i'll explain him in
a second too but there are a whole bunch of
easter eggs here and objects from the first
captain america movie like there's his original
motorcycle that he rode during world war ii
there's the very first version of the shield from
before he actually got the real vibranium shield
there's his backpack there's this helmet there's a
copy of the captain america number one comic book
that's actually the real captain america comic
book too the actual cover they circulated this
during the real world war ii i think that they
even have one of his drawings here like the
drawing of the monkey from the first captain
america movie that he was drawing because you
remember that steve rogers was a cartoonist before
he became captain america and joined the military
then when war machine says i'll be in touch and
leaves i think that's just a reference to him
coming back and cameoing in a future episode later
this season he'll have his own disney plus series
next year it'll be the iron man armor war series
so i'm assuming that they'll tease a little bit of
what's going on with that later in the falcon and
winter soldier episodes then we begin with winter
soldier for the first time since avengers end game
who's in the middle of having a nightmare about
one of his hydra missions from before the events
of the winter soldier movie in his full hydra
winter soldier gear with the original version
of his arm moving through a bunch of guards like
tissue paper he says hale hydra takes out this
scientist who we actually find out is the son of
yori the person that he's befriended in present
day he wakes up in a cold sweat in the most bare
bones shoebox size apartment you've ever seen
sleeping on the floor instead of on a bed just
as a way to address how he's still dealing with
the ptsd of his hydra brainwashing in the years of
work as an assassin shuri did deprogram him and he
does talk about his time in wakanda being really
amazing for him so the red book of hydra commands
won't work on him anymore but he still remembers
all the terrible things that he did so he still
has to work through the trauma of that the same
way that scarlet witch had to work through her
trauma and grief on the Wandavision episodes the
list of commands in that hydra book also show up
as an easter egg over the credits too at the end
of the episode we find out that he's in therapy
and that the therapy is part of the terms of his
us government pardon like they pardoned him for
all of his crimes as winter soldier but as part of
that he has this plan to make amends so to speak
that they sort of go through in a bunch of funny
moments where they address what he's actually
been doing since avengers end game quote-unquote
making amends by taking out other former hydra
operatives they reveal the therapist that he's
been visiting is the woman from the trailer that
you see while they're having the staring contest
when he starts getting on her case for doing the
unquote notebook thing that's also a callback to
the red hydra notebook then he talks about his
list that he's got which is another callback to
captain america's list in the winter soldier movie
like captain america had a list of things that he
wanted to do since coming out of the ice bucky
has his own list but it's all part of his plan
to make amends and a lot of the names on his list
are big comic book easter eggs from the winter
soldier comics and the captain america comics
then they show you and he narrates him crossing
one of the names off his list taking out one of
these senators that was working with hydra that
he helped install in the government so the name's
on his list it starts with rostov that's actually
the red barbarian character from the comics hauser
was a nazi agent from the captain america comics i
don't think that ganod and talasad are comic book
easter eggs but then you see baron zemo's name
obviously he's going to be a big character during
the series henriksen is the name of a us military
soldier that they tested the venom symbiote on
before they gave it to the flash thompson venom
the name sorry i think is a reference to
the character sorry tarter a character from
the 1940s world war ii era who just burned and
tortured victims the name osman doesn't ring any
comic book bells and then there are obviously
two kaminskys maybe brothers or father and
son but that's also the name of a hydra agent
that worked under garrett on agents of shield
kustanov is also the name of a russian scientist
who is associated with crimson dynamo but as we
see later in the episode there are a bunch of more
names in the book it's not like the whole list
is just this one page the entire book is full of
names they also let you know during this therapy
session that falcon has been trying to contact
winter soldier probably just to catch up and maybe
about eventually what's going to be happening
with them working together on these missions to
take down the flag smashers they also set up the
idea that because he's over 100 years old he's 106
years old everything is new to him now like he
has no connections no family that's alive anymore
they referenced that several times in a
couple funny moments later in the episode
we learned that he's moved back to brooklyn after
avengers end game where he and captain america
were originally from and winds up helping one of
his local friends yuri from starting a fight with
his neighbors who's just trying to use his trash
bin this also sort of dovetails with the idea that
he's trying to make amends but we learned that
he's actually probably befriended him out of guilt
for killing his son who was apparently either
working against or working with hydra someone that
hydra wanted him to get rid of but it takes the
rest of the episode to sort of tease it out but
they sort of set the stage in a couple different
scenes where he talks about not knowing how his
son died it's so mysterious and then when he's
on his date with the waitress she references the
same thing too it must be so hard not knowing how
he really died what was really going on there he
does try to come clean and tell him the truth but
he kind of chickens out at the last moment when he
sees the shrine to his son there it's not all bad
though they do have a lot of comedy about him just
trying to go out on dates like he references using
online dating like it's all crazy oh you talk like
my father huh that's kind of funny apparently the
waitress even though he's a regular at this sushi
bar doesn't really know anything about him doesn't
know the fact that he's really the winner soldier
that he has a vibranium arm like why do you wear
that glove all the time and when he reveals that
he is 106 years old she just laughs it off like
it's a joke when he makes a reference to not
having danced since 1943 that's actually around
the time that he was rescued by captain america
after red skull captured experimented on him and
gave him a version of the super soldier serum
there were also a couple easter eggs when they're
playing the battleship game together drinking
battleship which he's pretty bad at like he winds
up drinking a lot when they start calling out the
battleship designations too those are some easter
eggs so when he calls out f4 that's actually a
reference to his backstory f4 is the military
classification for someone who is unfit for duty
and because of all the ptsd mental health issues
he has he's kind of unfit for duty so to speak he
references his sister that he used to be close
to and his parents who are all dead now because
he's super old but because he lives in this
neighborhood and it seems like he frequents this
sushi bar we'll see if he comes back later in
the series and has a better version of a date
with this woman then we pick back up with falcon
in his family's home in louisiana we learn he has
a younger sister with nephews who was basically
trying to survive on her own during the five year
time jump they have this fishing family business
that they're trying to keep alive and they kind of
let you know that being an avenger does not pay
the bills like even falcon who was an avenger
fought thanos defended the planet help bring back
half of the universe still does not qualify for
a small business loan did stark pay you while you
were doing all that stuff oh sorry condolences by
the way like they make a joke about iron man dying
at the end of avengers end game so the public does
have some idea of what happened during that big
fight but there's a lot of things that they don't
know like what really happened to old man captain
america then back in switzerland you actually
meet the flag smashers his teammates trying to
learn what's going on with them so he tries to
infiltrate their group you meet aaron kellyman's
character for the first time but you don't see her
with the mask off like they don't fully reveal
what's going on with them but you do find out
that one of them is crazy strong just sort of
setting the stage for this whole deluded version
of the super soldier serum that it seems like the
flag smashers have but it's sort of the same idea
with the captain america civil war flashback
scenes with the hydra super soldiers like you
have a group of super soldiers that are kind of
like the villain group running around falcon seems
like he starts to put some of the pieces together
like this kind of seems like a big captain america
super soldier thing but he hasn't completely
put the pieces together but right on cue they
introduced the newest super soldier because it's
all part of a weapons plus storyline the us agent
version of captain america on tv and instantly
falcon looks like he regrets giving the shield
back like oh no because the whole speech that
government official or the military official gives
is about well you know it was great that we have
all these heroes to defend the earth the planet
but we need a hero to protect specifically just
the united states like oh that doesn't sound good
it should give you an idea of the kind of energy
that the us agent captain america brings with him
he's more like a patsy for thunderbolt ross who
will do whatever he says u.s agent captain america
is very quick to violence is very quick to kill
people very quick to use force as you'll see in
future episodes he is like the darkest timeline
version of captain america not to be confused with
hydra cap who's a completely separate character
but then the credit scene basically tells you the
story of us agent captain america falcon's history
winter soldier's history in the marvel movies
the new theme song you see easter eggs for all the
characters along with the flag smashers the symbol
from the other villain groups we're going to see
during the series there'll be smaller villain
groups that'll pop up from the comics you see a
bunch of baron zemo easter eggs the new version of
his mask the comic book costume that they give him
during the series you see a bunch of sharon carter
even though neither of those characters showed
up during episode 1 but overall i really enjoyed
the episode i feel like it's another slam dunk for
marvel on disney plus everyone just post all your
reactions and is there any big easter eggs you
spotted in the episode that i didn't talk about
in the video just write them below in the comments
but it's just the beginning we'll probably learn
more about what's going on with the new version of
the super soldier program the weapons plus program
and the us asian captain america during episode
2. my full episode 2 video will post next friday
just like normal it's the same schedule as
the Wandavision episodes but i'll be doing
bonus videos in between now and then everyone
click here for that brand new falcon and winter
soldier trailer video and click here for my new
justice league snyder cut ending video for the big
end credits scenes thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!